we're not quite finished talking about  the queen's bottom jubilee celebrity  we're going from this to all over this  has to be though one of my favorite um  moments from the weekend the queen  invited a very special guest for tia  bucky and palace the adorable paddington  bear i know this is so cute so in a  pre-recorded skit that aired ahead of  the platinum party at the palace her  majesty was joined by the beloved bear  as they bonded over their love for  marmalade sandwiches marmalade or  marmalade marmalade  um  and this was kept top secret not even  members of the royal family knew about  it yes take a look and we will see you  next time bye  um  perhaps  you would like a marmalade sandwich  i always keep on for emergencies  so do i  i keep mine in here  for later  [Applause]  [Music]  the party is about to start your majesty  happy jubilee man  and  thank you  for everything  that's very kind